des manifestations qui s'enchaînent
depuis presque trois mois deux milieux
et de tendances politiques différents
les protestataires y viennent par
milliers ils se rassemblent dans la
capitale presque quotidiennement pour
dénoncer la corruption et réclamé la
démission du premier ministre boiko
borisov
absolument personne ne semble se soucier
du fait que tant de personnes
manifestent pendant si longtemps mais je
le ressens comme une sorte d'obligation
envers moi personnellement et envers les
autres aussi je ne peux pas imaginer que
je vais rester chez moi pendant qu'ici
quelqu'un d'autre fait mon travail
le travail de tous les citoyens lutter
contre les injustices
personne ne se battra contre les
injustices à notre place c'est à nous de
le faire
personnellement je me sens déjà un peu
découragés parce que le gouvernement ne
donne pas le signe qu'il va démissionner
il ya donc un certain désespoir mais les
gens également accumulé tellement de
colère que c'est très probablement ceux
qui les emmène encore ici le fait qu'ils
ont malgré tout le droit de venir et de
clamer leur revendication de se
rassembler sur la place et de scander
démission
les manifestants reprochent au premier
ministre son projet de révision de la
constitution il la puce aussi
d'instrumentaliser la justice
ce sont d'ailleurs des perquisitions
menées le 9 juillet dernier au siège de
la présidence qui ont allumé les flammes
de la contestation au pouvoir depuis
presque 10 ans boyko borisov refuse de
démissionner au nom de la stabilité du
pays dans un contexte de crise sanitaire
international son mandat expire en mars
prochain